alors c'est un album que vous avez fait
et dit en collaboration avec notre
complice pierre papadiamandis ce1
alors ce qui est bizarre effectivement
c'est cliff est d'abord la musique et
après vous faites les paroles alors que
l'habitude par excès d'un verre ben je
sais pas c'est peut-être l'un vers 5h
que nous on a toujours travaillé
oui en fait au départ vous vouliez pas
écrire de texte en particulier vous avez
dû 10 seulement les textes qu'on
m'apporte était tellement brûlés que je
me suis dit 'c'est je peux en faire
autant voix alors donc si vous n'avez
pas la musique vous arrivez pas à partir
quoi c'est ça de donateurs sinon j'aime
pas écrire donc ne peut pas faire des
rimes comme ça avec des grands cheveux
longs qui y vivent ne fait pas les
petits poèmes que quelqu'un mais on me
voit large rousset sa peau est donc je
sais pas faire alors vous cite les
paroles en fait non pas tellement
d'importance vous dites les gens
écoutent bob dylan depuis des années
savent pas ce qu'ils racontent
et il fera charnière pour le public
européen non lui tend alors frenchy vous
l'avez fait à los angeles
vous dites je travaille à los angeles
parce que là-bas au moins je suis sûr
m'emmerder avec donc de bosser c'est
vrai nom mais parce que c'est pas une
vie qui me passionne amusant mais enfin
moi je ne les retrouve pas c'est une
rude qu'à 3 1 km à une des pâtés de
maisons à un océan glacial des boîtes
qui ferment à une heure du matin enfin
c'est pas très latin à quoi tout ça
quand même donc bas donc quand on est
content qu'on ne travaille que ça va
donc là je suis sûre d'elle au studio à
leur jeu sale je bouge pas une oreille
vous n'êtes pas eu envie vous ce chien
êtes vous installé à los angeles avant
c'est marrant les françaises ont du mal
quand même avec la californie ont de
bien
fonctionné que prendre 80 km tout droit
vous avez été choqué on parlait tout à
l'heure de la guerre d'irak vous avez
été choqué par la position de la france
pendant la guerre vous l'avez approuvez
vous à moi je l'approuvé gt gt n 16
heures
cela s'est passé et j'appelais la france
pour avoir des nouvelles car aux états
unis c'était très très long ce cru sous
sous de gaulle en ce sens tu en 58 par
les jeux sont plutôt si le c'est à dire
qu'il n'y avait heureusement pas d'infos
non vous êtes en rarement vous exprimer
là dessus vous dites disserter sur
l'état du monde au journal de 20 heures
c'est pas mon truc
non c'est pas mon truc parce que je
crois que c'est réservé à des gens qui
doivent savoir de quoi il parle aussi
connaître c'est pas mon cas je suis
comme tout le monde j'ai la formation
qu'on me donne c'est ça vous choque
ce pouvoir qu'on donne aux c'est un bon
d'une façon générale à la télévision de
donner leur avis sur l'état du monde
c'est ceux qui sont en ce sens qu'il me
dérange c'est à dire que de dire ça
c'est bien ça c'est mal de disserter de
donner son avis son état d'âme sur des
choses que finalement quand on connais
pas assez je vais rejouer pour pour dire
que je sais pas moi tel tel pays vit
sous une dictature etc faut savoir de
quoi on cause quoi bon je serais
incapable moins de jeux sera incapable
de dire ce qui se passait réellement en
irak avant la guerre vous la voulez
effet beaucoup